>>> GOOD EVENING.
THE LAWYER FOR FACEBOOK
WHISTLE-BLOWER FRANCES HAUGEN
JOINS US TONIGHT ON THE EVE OF
HER TESTIMONY BEFORE SENATE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND PERHAPS, IT WAS JUST A
COINCIDENCE BUT TODAY, THE
WORLD'S LARGEST SOCIAL NETWORK
WENT DOWN.
FACEBOOK AND FACEBOOK-OWNED
INSTAGRAM AND WHATSAPP WERE ALL
UNREACHABLE FOR MUCH OF THE DAY.
PROMPTING ONE TWITTER USER TO
WRITE HALF JOKINGLY, INSTAGRAM
AND FACEBOOK ARE CURRENTLY NOT
WORKING AS OUR DEMOCRACY,
SOCIETY, AND A HEALTHY SENSE OF
SELF.
EXCEPT, IT'S NO JOKE ACCORDING
TO THE WHISTLE-BLOWER IN
QUESTION.
FORMER-FACEBOOK EMPLOYEE,
FRANCES HAUGEN, WHO REVEALED
HERSELF LAST NIGHT ON CBS NEWS'S
60 MINUTES.
>> WHEN WE LIVE IN AN
INFORMATION ENVIRONMENT THAT IS
FULL OF ANGRY, HATEFUL,
POLARIZING CONTENT, IT ERODES
OUR CIVIC TRUST.
IT ERODES OUR FAITH IN EACH
OTHER.
IT ERODES OUR ABILITY TO WANT TO
CARE FOR EACH OTHER.
THE VERSION OF FACEBOOK THAT
EXISTS TODAY IS TEARING OUR
SOCIETIES APART, AND CAUSING
ETHNIC VIOLENCE AROUND THE
WORLD.
>> TEARING OUR SOCIETY APART.
NO JOKE AND NO ACCIDENT, SHE
SAYS.
SHE'S GOT EVIDENCE OR DOCUMENTS
TO GO WITH THAT CLAIM.
HAUGEN LEFT FACEBOOK IN MAY,
TAKING WITH HER A TROVE OF
INTERNAL COMPANY DOCUMENTS WHICH
SHE SENT TO LAWMAKERS, FEDERAL
REGULATORS, AND THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL."
ON THE PROGRAM LAST NIGHT, CBS
QUOTED ONE OF THOSE DOCUMENTS.
>> Reporter: WE HAVE EVIDENCE
FROM A VARIETY OF SOURCES THAT
HATE SPEECH, DIVISIVE POLITICAL
SPEECH, AND MISINFORMATION ON
FACEBOOK AND THE FAMILY OF APPS
ARE AFFECTING SOCIETIES AROUND
THE WORLD.
>> NOW, THE COMPANY KNEW THIS,
SHE SAYS, AND MADE CHANGES IN
2018 TO THE COMPUTER PROGRAMMING
THAT IT USES.
THE ALGORITHMS TO DETERMINE
WHICH ITEMS OUT OF POTENTIALLY
THOUSANDS YOU ACTUALLY SEE ON
YOUR FACEBOOK NEWS FEED.
>> AND ONE OF THE CONSEQUENCES
OF HOW FACEBOOK IS PICKING OUT
THAT CONTENT TODAY IS IT IS
OPTIMIZING FOR CONTENT THAT GETS
ENGAGEMENT OR REACTION.
BUT ITS OWN RESEARCH IS SHOWING
THAT CONTENT THAT IS HATEFUL,
THAT IS DIVISIVE, THAT IS
POLARIZING, IT'S EASIER TO
INSPIRE PEOPLE TO ANGER THAN IT
IS TO OTHER EMOTIONS.
>> MISINFORMATION.
ANGRY CONTENT.
>> YEAH.
>> IS ENTICING TO PEOPLE AND --
>> VERY ENTICING.
>> -- KEEPS THEM ON THE
PLATFORM?
>> YES.
FACEBOOK HAS REALIZED THAT IF
THEY CHANGE THE ALGORITHM TO BE
SAFER, PEOPLE WILL SPEND LESS
TIME ON THE SITE.
THEY'LL CLICK ON LESS ADS.
THEY'LL MAKE LESS MONEY.
>> AND IS THAT'S THE BOTTOM
LINE, YET FACEBOOK, WHETHER OUT
OF FEAR OF LAWSUITS OR SIMPLE
DECENCY OR WHATEVER, DID MAKE
CHANGES AHEAD OF THE 2020
ELECTION.
NOW, DESPITE THAT, AS WE HAVE
BEEN REPORTING FOR MORE THAN A
YEAR AND A HALF NOW, THE
PREELECTION SOCIAL MEDIA WORLD
WAS FULL OF ANGRY
MISINFORMATION, INCLUDING, OF
COURSE, FROM THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
ANALYSIS BY THE LEFT-LEANING
MEDIA MATTERS ORGANIZATION
REPORTED IN "THE WASHINGTON
POST" SHOWING THAT A QUARTER OF
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S FACEBOOK
POSTS FOR 2020 AND UNTIL THE
CAPITOL INSURRECTION, CONTAINED
EXTREMIST RHETORIC AND
MISINFORMATION ABOUT THE
ELECTION, COVID, OR HIS CRITICS.
THE STUDY USING FACEBOOK'S OWN
DATA-CRUNCHING TOOL FOUND THAT
THE PROBLEMATIC POSTINGS WERE
SHARED AND LIKED MORE THAN 927
MILLION TIMES.
AS YOU KNOW, HE WAS NOT THE ONLY
ONE.
MANY OF HIS SUPPORTERS WHO
ATTACKED THE CAPITOL EITHER
SHARED THEIR EXPLOITS ON
FACEBOOK OR SPREAD THE SO-CALLED
STOP THE STEAL MESSAGES ACROSS
THE NETWORK.
MAKING IT EASIER, HAUGEN SAYS,
THOSE PREELECTION CHANGES TO THE
ALGORITHM WHICH DIDN'T EVEN
FULLY WORK ANYHOW HAD BEEN
REVERSED.
>> AND AS SOON AS THE ELECTION
WAS OVER, THEY TURNED THEM BACK
OFF.
OR THEY CHANGED THE SETTINGS
BACK TO WHAT THEY WERE BEFORE TO
PRIORITIZE GROWTH OVER SAFETY.
AND THAT REALLY FEELS LIKE A
BETRAYAL OF DEMOCRACY TO ME.
>> WELL, THE QUESTION, THOUGH,
IS DOES FACEBOOK SEE IT THAT
WAY?
HERE'S CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER,
CHERYL SANDBERG, ON A REUTERS
PODCAST THE MONDAY AFTER THE
INSURRECTION.
>> I THINK THESE EVENTS WERE
LARGELY ORGANIZED ON PLATFORMS
THAT DON'T HAVE OUR ABILITIES TO
STOP HATE AND DON'T HAVE OUR
STANDARDS AND DON'T HAVE OUR
TRANSPARENCY.
>> NOW, KEEPING THEM HONEST,
CENTERS ON A WHISTLE-BLOWER SAYS
SOMETHING ABOUT TRANSPARENCY.
SANDBERG WENT ON TO SAY THAT THE
COMPANY BANNED SO-CALLED STOP
THE STEAL CONTENT FROM THE
PLATFORM.
SHE DIDN'T -- DID NOT MENTION,
HOWEVER, THAT FACEBOOK ONLY
IMPOSED THAT BAN AFTER THE
INSURRECTION.
IN ADDITION, A FACEBOOK INTERNAL
REPORT OBTAINED BY BUZZFEED NEWS
DESCRIBED THE COMPANY'S EFFORT
AGAINST STOP THE STEAL AS QUOTE
PIECEMEAL.
AGAIN, IF FRANCES HAUGEN IS TO
BE BELIEVED, BY THE TIME THE BIG
LIE STARTED SPREADING ACROSS
SOCIAL MEDIA, FACEBOOK ALREADY
REVERSED SOME OF THE MEASURES
THAT MIGHT HAVE ELIMINATED THE
DAMAGE BUT WHICH MIGHT HAVE ALSO
MADE THE COMPANY LESS MONEY.
MS. SANDBERG DID NOT MENTION
THAT IN HER PODCAST INTERVIEW
AND LISTEN TO WHAT MARK
ZUCKERBERG SAID ABOUT ALL THIS
DURING CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY
BACK IN MARCH.
>> WE REMOVED CONTENT THAT COULD
LEAD TO REAL-WORLD IMMINENT
HARM.
WE BUILT AN UNPRECEDENTED
THIRD-PARTY FACT CHECKING
PROGRAM AND WE HAVE WARNING
LABELS AND SIGNIFICANTLY -- ITS
DISTRIBUTION.
WE INVEST A LOT IN DIRECTING
BILLIONS OF PEOPLE TO
AUTHORITATIVE INFORMATION.
THE SYSTEM ISN'T PERFECT BUT
IT'S THE BEST APPROACH THAT
WE'VE FOUND TO ADDRESS
MISINFORMATION IN LINE WITH OUR
COUNTRY'S VALUES.
>> WE HAVE HEARD SIMILAR WORDS
FROM THE COMPANY, BEFORE.
IN THE WAKE OF CHARLOTTESVILLE
IN 2017, WHEN WHITE NATIONALISTS
USED FACEBOOK TO SPREAD HATE.
AFTER THE CAMBRIDGE ANALYTICA
SCANDAL WHEN TRUMP CONSULTANTS
EXPLOITED DATA OF MILLIONS OF
FACEBOOK USERS.
WE EVER HEARD IT THROUGHOUT A
YEAR AND A HALF OF COVID
MISINFORMATION, FACEBOOK HAS
PROMISED TO CHANGE.
AND TO ITS CREDIT, THE COMPANY
HAS MADE CHANGES BUT THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN ENOUGH.
CERTAINLY, ACCORDING TO THIS
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
ONLY NOW, THANKS TO -- BECAUSE
OF THIS WHISTLE-BLOWER, WE HAVE
A BETTER PICTURE PERHAPS OF THE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES THAT
FACEBOOK HAS NOT TO CRACK DOWN
HARDER AND A BETTER SENSE OF
WHAT THE COMPANY, ITSELF, KN